John we've had a question come in from
Karen reader and her Twitter handle is
at movie hood and she writes what does
it take to submit a spec script for TV
well first of all you've got to have a
really good spec script and a lot of
writers think is that the big obstacle
is sending the script in and that
certainly is an obstacle because you do
need an agent to get it through the door
to have somebody look at it but by far
the bigger obstacle that writers face is
writing a spec script that's good enough
to be sent in in the first place and
this is where learning the craft is so
important and we're writing a spec
script of a particular show and
executing it really well is so important
keep in mind that when you send a spec
script in it will be read by someone of
where whatever shows they send the spec
script to it will be read by somebody on
that show and what they're looking for
is did you execute the way this show is
done because each show has a very
specific set of rules so we do these
things and we don't do those things and
if you don't know that and you make the
mistake for example some shows do not
have cliffhangers they won't do that and
if you write cliffhangers in your
episode it's out they want to see can
you write this show because remember
that that's very challenging for writer
this is not something that you are
creating from scratch as you would with
a spec movie script this is you are
writing a story for a show that's
already been created for characters that
have already been created can you get
your voice into that show that's what
they're looking for and can you tell a
great story one of the things I always
talk about
the TV sitcom class is that the
perception of writers trying to break in
is that a sitcom is stringing as many
jokes as you can get in 22 minutes it's
all about the jokes can you make people
laugh when they read the script
certainly the jokes are important but
any producer on any sitcom on the air
will tell you that what they look for in
a spec script is the story they can have
the jokes later they're not worried
about that what's hard to come up with
is a sitcom story that will be appealing
to the audience that can be the
structure the framework to hang the
jokes on and that's a talent most
writers don't have so again I'm just
trying to get the focus onto the real
problem that has to be solved if you're
a writer trying to break in which is
write a great spec script because this
is the calling card that makes all the
difference that is what makes or breaks
your career if you want to work in
television
and know the show that you're submitting
the script to don't do exactly you have
to know that show top to bottom and
that's why as I was saying earlier one
of the ways you determine which show to
write for is it's not just a show that's
highly respected by the critics that's
popular with the audience it's a show
that you love that you watch religiously
so that you really know how that thing
works that's what they're looking for
under the surface
you